nato warns russia's war in ukraine could
last years both sides say negotiations
have broken down can the conflict be
ended through diplomacy and if so under
what conditions this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fully batibo it's now nearly four months
since russia invaded ukraine casualties
are mounting on both sides russia is
intensifying its offensive to seize
strategic towns in eastern ukraine the
head of nato and britain's prime
minister warned the conflict could last
years both have urged western
governments to keep sending military
support to ukraine to halt russian
advances
diplomatic negotiations appear to have
stalled ukrainian and russian delegates
last held face-to-face talks in istanbul
in march they've since held meetings by
video link but ukraine's president says
they've made little progress
the keeper
such negotiations are currently at zero
everyone really wants to push us little
by little towards some result that is
definitely undesirable for us because we
have not yet been asked but beneficial
for other parties that have their own
interests
fatigue is growing people want some kind
of result for themselves and we need a
result
russia says the talks have reached a
dead end the kremlin has accused ukraine
of being inconsistent with its demands
here's what president vladimir putin
said in april the last time he addressed
the negotiations directly
the ukrainian side moved away from its
agreements in istanbul
now the requirements for security
guarantees is one thing and the
settlements of relations with crimea
sevastopol and the donbass are to be
taken outside of those agreements
so we are back in a dead-end situation
while negotiations between moscow and
keith began four days after russia
invaded low-level delegations from both
sides first met on ukraine's border with
belarus they came together again in
march for a second and third round where
they agreed to form some humanitarian
corridors the first high-level contact
took place in turkey during intense
fighting and bombardment in the
ukrainian port city of mariopol two
hours of tanks achieved snow
breakthroughs russia continued bombing
on april the 7th both sides announced
stocks were entering a new phase but
despite many rounds since no solid
ceasefire has been agreed
let's now bring in our guests in lev
dimitro suga european program director
at the international renaissance
foundation in brussels theresa fallon
director of the center for russia europe
asia studies and in moscow pavel
a defense and military analyst welcome
to you all thank you for being with us
on inside story dimitro in ukraine if i
can start with you there were hopeful
signs in early may but then negotiations
ground to a halt with each side accusing
each other uh for the collapse are the
conditions on the ground today and the
factors are they favorable to a
resumption of democrat diplomacy in your
opinion
i think now uh
the fate is being decided and the battle
and the battle of donbass for the east
of ukraine
uh position of the two sides are totally
totally controversial totally different
for russia it is aggressive a war of
conquest
and they basically now openly says the
russian officials openly say that their
goal is to seize ukrainian land and to
change ukraine's borders
and to dismantle ukrainian sovereignty
as a whole
for ukraine of course it's self-defense
so absolutely there's kind of little
ground for compromise here right so for
ukraine it's a totally different goal to
repel the attackers to the previously
contact line at least
held on
23rd of february so i think now it will
be
decided in the battle until
there is some developments there
we will not see i think any resumption
of meaningful assumption of meaningful
negotiation dimitro in what frame of
mind are the ukrainians right now the
russians have been progressing in the
east even you know if if slowly do the
ukrainians still believe that they can
uh win that with more western powers and
ammunition that they can turn the tide
yes yes sure i mean ukrainian results is
is the is here is there
and uh ukraine is fighting and the mood
is uh absolutely
resolutive that we need to fight we need
to defend our land
uh of course there was expectation
probably that it will take less time it
will be like uh
not this
long
uh war of attrition but it by kind of
all signs are there that it will take
longer than expected i think expected by
everyone including by russians as well
okay let's get the view from russia with
pavel what's the mood like in moscow
pavel is there any appetite in moscow to
return to the negotiating table
well the official russian position is
that russia is ready to talk
but the ukrainians do not want to and
they don't they know the russian
position they know what they should
accept
they are not ready to accept and that
means well it's all going to be
both sides agreed to disagree agreed to
log it out on the battlefield the good
old way
and of course yes the positions of the
two sides have been miles apart or they
will be have been miles apart from
basically the very beginning
us
moscow in moscow actually the war is not
felt at all it's a very kind of peaceful
city
um the general public kind of mostly
tends to make
act as if there is no wars or this is a
far so happening somewhere in the far of
land there's reports of course about
officials official about the war
happening about russia the success of
russian and so-called allied troops from
the donbas small republics um
battering the ukrainians kind of
grinding them uh into pope and that this
is going to the russian operation is
going to
end in success but no one knows when
right and this is basically more or less
accepted by the russian but what about
the sanctions
but what about the sanctions pavel the
sanctions and the fact that russia is
isolated is not not resonating with
people
uh yes of course that's well known that
russia is actually isolated though of
course again the official line is that
uh arab nations
china india uh latin america africa is
more western it's the west that is
against us uh but this kind of has
actually helped the authorities to rally
the
large portion of the public around uh
the kremlin that we are surrounded by
are attacked by uh very powerful enemies
and we should act together and support
uh the the effort of the
kremlin and the president and that
everything is going to be okay
okay let's bring teresa into the
conversation now teresa warring sides
come to talks when there's a stalemate
in a conflict or when one side has one
do you feel that we are at a point in
this war in ukraine where both sides
could be ready to talk again
it seems that that's a bit premature at
this point i think that uh zielinski
president zielinski has made it quite
clear that
he wouldn't be able to give up territory
although he has said that he wants to
continue dialogue and negotiations with
russia the the war has turned on such um
so there have been so many deaths on
both sides the idea of negotiations
before we're kind of you have to give up
some territory to to russia so i think
that this was one of the the deal
breakers and i think that
as long as this continues on as it
grinds on as we've heard uh the head of
nate uh jen stoltenberg from nato
the analysis is that this will grind on
for quite a long time the key question
now is will europe be able to remain
unified because we see increasing
inflation high energy prices and
energy and food are are deeply connected
so when you have high energy prices you
will also have high food prices in
addition to the blockade of
food leaving
ukraine that's being stopped so we're
seeing a huge issue maybe russia thinks
that they can play this for what it's
worth and see europe divide it right
nevertheless saw france italy and
germany go to kiev by train and they
have announced that
ukraine will be a candidate country for
new membership how long that will take
remains to be seen but that's kind of a
vote of confidence and supports uh
ukraine indeed nato secretary general
teresa has said that uh you know ukraine
will require long-term military support
and indeed the ukrainians are pretty
much dependent on on decision and
support from washington paris to
european union do you get a sense that
this support is now waning
as the war drags on and that it could
there could be some let up in in
supporting
ukraine because of these divisions that
you spoke about within european
countries
i know ukraine is worried about fatigue
perhaps in europe but we see that the us
is the biggest supplier right now of
equipment and material so germany has
been dragging their feet they've been
making promises and not delivering and
this is a worrisome message also france
andre macron has sent
mixed messages about
ukraine saying that we cannot uh
humiliate russia so this really went
down early in europe nevertheless france
has been sending so weaponry it's kind
of not reported so loudly but i think
that there is a real division growing
in europe we see the central eastern
european member states who have a lot
more empathy
for and support for ukraine because of
their past history and we see other
countries trying to make calculations
in regard to energy and inflation and i
have to get reelected so i think putin
has played a very dangerous game here
because now his biggest
client which is europe he earns 250 to
300 billion a year in energy payments
from europe he has now decided to
recklessly put that on the line in order
by turning off the tap to many countries
in europe they are never going to go
back to such high dependency on russian
energy and other countries like china
will not pick up the slack they might
pick up a little bit of it but china is
very clever about diversifying they will
not allow russia to do the same thing to
them that they're doing to europe so i
think that putin has really put himself
in a corner and he's it's in my view
almost total war he doesn't care anymore
if he loses these markets dimitro uh
teresa alluded to the conditions some of
the conditions and the non-negotiating
position of ukraine when it comes for
example to its territorial integrity but
do you think there could be some
movement on some of these red lines if
this war drags on and ukraine has to to
give up something what would they be
willing to give
up i don't know really i mean
territorial integrity is really
non-negotiable for sure
and
whatever
future peace agreement there could be
we have already had the experience of
having agreements with russia
and the
uh including for instance the uh
so-called minsk agreements brokered by
germany and france
uh in 2014 2015
and we've seen that basically russia did
how it basically used those agreements
those agreements basically provided
some
form of
settlement in the way that uh
ukraine would give some uh
self-governance uh
provisions for those uh
lands occupied by russia this at that
time in the east of ukraine and
while russia will uh withdrew its forces
from from there but russia never did do
its forces from there actually they used
all the opportunity to defuck to occupy
the fact to annex that those territories
and now they use
those territories to further attack
ukraine and actually to also use even
manpower uh mobilized from from those
territories actually now serving for the
russian army and basically used as a
cannon flash for the russian army to
attack ukrainian forces right so from
that perspective from this experience so
we understand that we never can uh
accept any sort of deal
uh
implying uh refusing from parts of
ukrainian lands right what what other
things can be there uh where what could
be negotiated i mean i don't know maybe
there might be some negotiations about
security arrangements uh
particular things about i don't know uh
some uh
security
confidence building measures and so on
but i mean it's it's kind of now
speculation because we really don't know
the parameters the key parameters of the
future right diplomatic resolution of
the conflict because it is
really depends on the key security thing
which is where the front line will be
there
uh what what uh what conditions will be
what what will who basically who will
win will will win this morning let me
bring in um um pavel
to talk about this what pavel could be
the negotiation negotiated rather as far
as russia is concerned in previous
negotiations russia
insisted about maintaining
control over large parts of ukraine is
that still the case today what would
they be willing to negotiate at this
point
uh well apparently moscow the key demand
is that
any kind of government or future
government in kiev will recognize crimea
as sovereign russian territory
and also so that sanctions can be
removed and also recognize the
independence of these small
donbass republics that russia has
already recognized and then
maybe there could be some kind of
negotiations about other territories in
uh zappos west and uh
her son oblast that russia has since
occupied that maybe also could go
somewhere but maybe that's negotiable i
don't know
uh but it's understood also that ukraine
and government right now is not ready to
talk take those conditions
so that russia right now the russian
strategy is to grind the ukrainian
military grind their morale it's uh the
the pitched battle in the town bus right
now it's very similar to the bird the
sea the storming of in siege of verdan
by the germans in 1916 when they didn't
have enough forces to get have a no
all-out offensive on the western front
they concentrated on one fortress
that were done
using their
firepower superiority to kill as much
french as possible and break them around
the french army and right now russia is
trying to do more or less the same of
course in a very different uh level of
usage of power and men
but they they're apparently ukrainians
are suffering their military heavy
casualties that could affect morale and
if ukrainian morale begins to snap
then most likely the ukraine would be
ready to take the russian conditions
okay teresa right now we are at a point
where neither side uh wants to give up
anything
so
what is it going to take in your view to
end the stalemate
i think we also have to zoom back a bit
on the bigger geopolitical questions
here we see the u.n security council two
members of them
of the security council supporting this
war so it's a question of sovereignty we
know that beijing is watching what
happens here very very closely and
they're making their own calculus in
regard to taiwan so these issues of
sovereignty i think are key will the
europeans just sit back like they did in
2014 after crimea this is a much bigger
issue so i think but there are those who
say well ask whether european support
for ukraine long-time european support
for ukraine is justified
well as i mentioned there are some
divisions within europe on that there
will be a meeting this coming week the
eu council which they will discuss this
further on the american side is quite
interesting because i understand that
there is less discussion between moscow
and washington dc than there was at the
time of the cuban missile crisis and i
think that's a worrying message right
there and the back channel reportedly is
dr henry kissinger who is actually 99
years old so he had counseled that
ukraine give up some territory so i
think that that didn't fly very well and
i think that over the longer term uh
many analysts in in washington dc are
concerned
that the us is taking the eye off the
ball in regard to china they're worried
about getting bogged down in a very very
long drawn-out affair here in ukraine
alternatively some see it as a way to
weaken russia over the longer term right
so there are very different viewpoints
on this and russia is becoming more and
more isolated and their economy is
really going to suffer theresa some
experts have suggested that we could end
up uh with a scenario like the one on
the korean peninsula where ukraine is
divided into two parts
without a formal treaty and that such a
division would allow
the western allied part of ukraine to
prosper in the same way that south korea
has do you see this at all
well my personal opinion would be that
that would send a rather negative
message uh russia definitely wants this
kind of buffer zone but the ukrainians
have made such a huge sacrifice uh in
blood sweat and tears to paraphrase
churchill would that be really the right
thing to do at this stage i think it's
too early to tell how the negotiations
will take place i think that it's
untenable for zielinski to give up any
territory that is an interesting uh
idea but as we see that there's a great
deal of instability on the korean
peninsula with north korea and nuclear
weapons and let's remember that ukraine
gave up their nuclear weapons and that
all these countries under the budapest
memorandum uh pledged to support them
and guarantee their sovereignty and that
really hasn't held water so that sends
also a dangerous message to iran and
north korea all right dmitry your
thoughts about this some of the possible
scenarios that have been put out there
like you know uh ukraine ending up
in a situation like the one on the
korean peninsula
and you know where do you see things
heading and what would be the minimum
acceptable agreement for ukraine
well this korean formula might be
one of the scenarios of course but uh
just let's not forget first
that uh
with uh
uh
with the i mean unlike in the korean
case we don't have really
two koreas or two ukraines fighting each
other we have basically ukrainian army
and the russian army so if we will have
a sort of
ceasefire agreement with the contact
line
there then it will be nothing between
some ukraine and another and another one
ukraine but it will be between ukraine
and russian forces
and uh
it's a key difference one and second is
the question how to implement the
ceasefire uh i mean it's
also
a big question because we again we have
uh our own experience of
of minsk agreements since 2014-15
where ceasefire was number one of
of delos agreements number one issue but
it was never implemented in full so it
was always
violated almost every day right by
russians uh and that's uh uh kind of
that's
that's a question how how it can be
enforced uh if it is enforced by
international
uh
i don't know peacekeeping forces whether
whether they're
whether there is any international
peacekeeping force ready to come to
enforce such a ceasefire so it's very
complicated issue i think yeah so
probably it's uh
it might be one of the scenarios but
just your thoughts
your thoughts there are various
scenarios out there about how this could
end do you think this could end through
diplomacy and if so how and when
well of course it will end um somehow
through diplomacy but before that
there's going to be a lot of fighting
and a lot of bloodshed
the summer campaign has just basically
began and it will last maybe at least
till this mid-september
maybe till october when the autumn rains
turn the soil into a sea of dirt the
rasputitsa and the fighting is going to
hold if not end it's going to at least
become more oppositions will be more
stable and it's clear that the
ukrainians hope that in august september
they could turn the tables and have a
strategic initiative and maybe go
against the russians in an offensive the
russians believe that they have the
capability to grind down the ukrainians
so that will be decided actually on the
battlefield who has the initiative who
has uh the upper hand and then that will
be translated somehow into a negotiating
that settlement may be
by new year maybe next year all right
teresa i'll give you the last word once
we get to a point where
the war is settled or resolved what will
be the future relationship
of all these countries that have
supported ukraine with russia
well it's been a very intricate tapestry
of interest and i think that europe
especially poland has really risen to
this challenge they have been such a
huge advocate for ukraine so
the fact that ukraine will be a
candidate country will help give them
the goal of reform and give the people
some hope a more morale boost it remains
to be seen if they will join the eu but
this actually provides them a road map
to the future uh politically i wonder if
that will really happen but i do hope
that this will help them to
reform and prevent corruption but also
we have to see that as pavel mentioned
he gave the example of going back to
world war one the piece in europe is
over we can't take any of these things
for granted any longer and we see the
authoritarian march of both
russia and china and these are huge
questions for us and they're perhaps a
dress rehearsal for what we're going to
see in in asia so i think that uh europe
has to stay united and strong and it's
and bunker down for the long haul and in
regards to energy prices and the winter
that's going to be coming we see that
moscow has cut off uh energy and that's
the traditional period in the summer is
to fill up the
storage facility so i suggest everybody
start getting some sweaters so thank you
okay thank you all very much for a very
interesting discussion dimitro shulker
teresa fallon and pavel felgenhauer
and thank you for watching you can watch
this program again anytime by visiting
our website at aljazeera.com
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can of
course also join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
from me fully [ __ ] the whole team
here in doha thanks for watching bye for
now
you